so we have a company here let's just say
it's a widget factory again or widget
company and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to actually
write out its income statement over a
given number of years what we did in the
first video on on this kind of series is
we just did one snapshot of the income
statement i think it was 2008 but here
we're looking at the income statement
for over a bunch of years and in this
case i'm just assuming that they have
very a very stable revenue base that
they bring in a very stable amount of
revenue every year
now their cost of goods
i'm going to split up this time because
there's two components of cost of goods
so i'll just make a cost of goods
category right here cogs is what that
just stands for cost of goods sold but
sometimes you'll hear someone say our
cogs were this or cogs were that cost of
goods sold so there was a there are the
variable costs and this video isn't a
video on variable versus fixed costs but
you might learn a little bit about it
so there are the variable costs and
that's literally the actual costs of
making those widgets so if the widgets
are made out of stainless steel it's the
cost of buying the stainless steel and
maybe the energy
the the electricity bill of melting it
and reforming it or however you have to
work with stainless steel so let's say
the variable cost
each of these years and i'm assuming
stainless steel prices don't change it's
i don't know i'd say it's 100k
minus 100k every year
minus 100k
every year
and actually let's just say that the
variable that also includes employee
costs they have people on on hourly
wages that are are forming these these
stainless steel widgets so that
incorporates everything and then the
fixed cost would essentially be the cost
of the factory and let's say that these
factories
they essentially have to build a new
factory every two years or let's say
they have to do major repairs to the
factory every two years so let's say
repairs on factory because that's part
of the the cost of of building the
widgets because
if you continue to make widgets at this
kind of one million dollars a year pace
your factory has to be retooled or
revamped every two years so let's put
this fixed cost
so the factory retooling
factory retooling
and most times and we'll see this when
you look at a actual company's income
statement they're not going to break up
the variable and fixed cost within their
cost of goods sold like this because
really they actually want to hide it
from a lot of their competitors they
don't want their competitors to have too
much intelligence on what what their
cost structure is like
it could be used against them
potentially or they maybe don't want
their customers to know but anyway
factory retooling so the way i just
described it
one way to account for it is when you do
the factory retooling
you essentially just mark it as an
expense so let's say a factory retooling
costs five hundred thousand dollars so
let's say it's minus five hundred
thousand dollars
but they do it every two years
right so they didn't so you did it in
2005 they didn't have to do it in 2006
then they can do it in 2007
they don't have to do it in 2008 fair
enough
and then we have their gross profit
you have their gross profit
gross profit
here it's let's see one million minus
six hundred thousand it's 400k
then it's 900k
then it is 400k
and let's say that they're sg a
they're sg a
sgna they're selling general and
administrative expenses and i'll i'll
leave out marketing for now
their sg a let's say it's another four
hundred thousand dollars let's say it's
a five hundred thousand every year so
minus five hundred
and that never changes
five hundred thousand every year
minus five hundred 000
and so their operating profit
the amount of
i guess pre-tax income but you know
we're not considering financing either
so this is their ebit their or actually
this is their operating profit or their
ebit so operating profit operating
profit
and this year is
minus
100k
here it's also minus 100k
but then in these years they make money
it's 400k
and 400k
and then we could take this down let's
say they have no interest expense so
interest
they have no interest expense because
that's not the point of this video and
then their pre-tax
pre-tax expense a pre-tax profit
is going to be the same thing as the
operating profit so minus 100k
minus 100k
400k i'll make the goodyears in green
400k
and then let's just say they're in i
don't know they're in the caribbean they
don't have to pay taxes because that's
not the point of this but you could
figure out you could apply some tax rate
to this and figure out what their net
income is but the point of this is
even though their business is ultra
stable they do the exact same thing
every year when we look at the pre-tax
or the operating income or if we tax it
or even at the net income we see a super
lumpy business because in one year they
lost a hundred thousand dollars if
you're looking at the business you're
like oh what a horrible business but
then the next year they make four
hundred thousand dollars and then they
lose a hundred thousand dollars you're
like gee how is that possible that you
have such a sleepy stable business
that's just making cogs year in year out
you have the exact same amount of
revenue how is it possible that their
actual income is so lumpy and i think
you know because
you have this every other year factory
retooling where they have to spend five
hundred thousand dollars to essentially
get their factory rebuild their factory
because of all of the wear and tear that
happened over the last over the last two
years
and so the question is is this a good
way to account for it where
when you have to i guess you could say
buy new equipment let's say this 500 000
is to buy actual new
stainless steel shaping tools so is it a
good idea to account for it only in the
period that you spend it because it's
not like
it's not like you're only using these
tools in this period and that period
you're using these tools
throughout the period
so the the answer is well no no it's not
a good idea because the whole purpose of
accounting is to give the
the person reading the the income
statement in this in this case as
accurate a picture of the actual state
of the business as possible and this in
my opinion isn't an accurate picture
where it creates this huge lumpiness and
it creates the impression of a volatile
business even though it's a super super
stable business so what you do instead
of just saying oh i had to buy five
hundred thousand dollars worth of
equipment in 2005 so i literally put a
500 000 expense there and i didn't have
to do that in 2006 so i have no expense
i had to do it in 2007 so i put the
expense instead of doing that
what you do is i'll put the balance
sheet down here
so whatever the balance sheet was in
whoops
so i'll just draw the left hand side
well actually i'll draw both hand sides
of the balance sheet
so the assets
so in 2000
and i want to make that a thicker line
so in 2000 and
this is the asset side of the balance
sheet and i'll just just so you don't
get confused there's always a liability
side of the balance sheet as well
so in 2007 maybe before
i spent the 500 000
right right when i do it i probably had
500 000 of cash sitting here
so let me write that down so i have cash
i'll just put a c there cash 500k
and instead of just using this as an
expense and we'll go in the future on
kind of how you account for things a
little bit more detail on how you
actually do the debits and credits but a
simple way to think about it instead of
using this 500 000 expense we just
transferred this 500 000 to buy an asset
so when you
have a when you use cash to buy an asset
and that asset has a useful life that's
more than just that period you're
essentially capitalizing the expense or
you're essentially creating that asset
on the balance sheet so instead of this
500 000 just disappearing expense you
say no now i have let's call it f for
factory tools i have factory tools worth
five hundred thousand dollars and then
that cash will go away so your assets
will not have really changed the
absolute value of the assets you will
just have 500 000 going from cash to new
factory tools
and so this might be at the beginning of
oh when you do it let's say this is 1
and what you say is i'm going to use
these factory tools they're usable over
two years so what you do is you
depreciate the tools so
the way you think about this instead of
having factory retooling what you do is
well you could say factory tool
instead of retooling i'll recall i'll
call that depreciation
depreciation
i don't know if you can read that
d-e-p-r-e-c-i-a-t-i-o-n depreciation so
it essentially spreads out the cost of
that five hundred thousand dollars a
year so you say i had a five hundred
thousand dollar piece of capital
equipment and i
half of it it's useful life is two years
so i use half of it in year one so
instead of putting five hundred thousand
there
the depreciation is minus two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars likewise and
this year no cash went out the door but
my equipment got a little bit older so
i used half more of it so it's two
hundred fifty thousand dollars and then
my equipment is worthless
so this is in one one two thousand seven
i have this this
this tool that's worth five hundred
thousand dollars
then on one one two thousand
actually where did i start this was two
thousand and five so there's one one two
thousand five
then on 1 1 2006
i will have used half of the tool
so
now
this balance sheet
oh i recovered i copied the numbers too
but that's 2006 i'm going from 2005 to
2006.
so now i will have used up half of it
so i now have this if i
according to the accounting this
equipment is no longer worth five
hundred thousand dollars it's now worth
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
you know that actually might make sense
maybe if i were to sell into the open
market someone might say you know what
i'm only willing to pay 250 000 because
you've already used it for a year and
only has one year of useful life left so
it's of 250 000 of value to me and then
the other 250 000 essentially went to an
expense called depreciation which was
right there so every year
you're going to have this asset go down
on the balance sheets by two hundred
fifty thousand dollars and then
so here you would go the asset would be
worth at the beginning of this year the
assets worth five hundred thousand
dollars so i'll write that up here so
this is what the assets value i'll do it
in i'll do it in this orange color so
over here right let's say you did it
right at the beginning of the year the
asset's worth 500 000. now it's worth
250 000. now the asset's worth zero but
at the beginning of this year you buy a
new asset worth five hundred thousand
then it's worth two hundred fifty
thousand again and the way this is just
a i guess an arguably long-winded way of
saying that the way you account for this
is you spread out the cost over time
over its useful life and this spreading
out is called the depreciation of an
asset and i'm running out of time in
this video and i'll cover it in the next
but you might have also heard of the
word of amortization amortization is to
spread out a non-tangible cost over a
period of time so for example
depreciation this was factory equipment
and it gets old as i use it so i spread
out its cost that's what depreciation
does and it accurately reflects what's
actually happening in the business you
know it's not like i didn't have any
cost here i did have costs i i'm using
an asset up so therefore i put it down
there amortization is the exact same
thing as depreciation or but it applies
to things that aren't equipment it
applies to and i'll do it in the next
video but let's say i had a one big
expense in terms of i had to pay a bunch
of fees to the bank but the the benefit
of those fees are going to be over time
then i would amortize those fees i'll do
that in the next video anyway hopefully
you found this vaguely useful